Sunday nights on HBO not just about
ballers and Game of Thrones which we
discuss at length here on the Rich Eisen
show in Secours and Sunday nights at
10:30 p.m. Eastern Time currently in
season two and one of the actors from
that hit show is Jay Ellis good to see
you here in studio sir how are you I'm
good man I'm doing fine we have to talk
first things first
um describe for my radio audience okay
what you are wearing up top oh oh it
does look like
I came as a referee for you like you
know I think you work with NFL every
once in a while
yes I do I heard that so I just thought
you know maybe I would just be real
official to this okay yeah like in like
in like an actual official yeah like I
mean sometimes you know college hoops
college yeah where that do you know and
would have been be a guy's honor they
were like a gracious yeah they do the
great thing you know they don't wear the
zebra stripes anymore and that but I
appreciate the spirit let you you know
flag on the play I thought I'd call it
out I appreciate that very good is do
you have an NFL team that you are a fan
of I am I am a Niner fan why would you
pause it's just why would you say that
hesitantly it's been rough it's River I
listen I love my team though I've never
I my dad grew up in Northern California
and he was a Niner fan where Northern
California - girl Sacramento okay so
I've just I've been an ina fan ever
since so like you know I think of Jerry
Rice and Montana and Steve Young and
like just all those amazing years sure
or Jim Harbaugh in Kappa you never
should have let go and cap who I think
you know is a phenomenal player that
just got putting a system that didn't
work out for him after Harbaugh left
multiple multiple cysts by the way I
fortunately right I'm hopeful to go gay
right yeah I mean look I'm a Michigan
guy so your guys are doing your losses -
well my cousin plays a toe you and I
think they're playing Michigan I think
I'm going to Michigan actually to see a
game are you serious yeah my cousin a
start and receiver at the University of
Oklahoma shout out Jordan Smallwood
wherever the cameras okay yeah and he I
think that plan at Michigan oh I don't
think that maybe and maybe not this year
could be could be nutria nation so your
your your you said your cousin's playing
for Oakland he's receivers actually new
this year yeah that's great and you you
have some college hoops
background college basketball by play I
mean I set the bench in practice a lot
how tall are you uh uh I'm about six
three and a half 6-4
okay I'm wearing there all right and so
what were your shooting guard point
yards I was a - well I couldn't shoot
man my handles were bad I was really I
could deal that was about that was
really all it was I mean that's that's
useful that's helpful it'll get you
that'll keep you on the floor yeah I
mean it'll keep you on the bench where
did you play your college hoops I played
a Concordia University in Portland
Oregon okay yeah so there was no big
dancing for you not essentially no no no
no I thought you know for a long time I
felt like I had those dreams that I
would like go to like the next level and
I was like oh like there's you hear all
these stories of guys who like come out
of like d3 schools and deeds from school
sure and they get a shot yes that wasn't
me
that didn't happen for no no no that
wasn't that wasn't me I was really good
at cheering my teammates on did you was
there anybody that you played against
that did move on or anything like that G
uh many we played against Y we played
one year we played against Dunleavy in
like a preseason scrimmage thing which
was pretty amazing cake against Duke
yeah that kid was like hold on a second
this was I was at a previous school
before that so that's a whole different
story okay but that was pretty amazing
but like everybody I played with most
most people in playing like you're not
getting one played overseas and now
you're on your own
insecure on HBO JLS Jamie here on the
Rich Eisen show now you interned with
the Portland Trailblazers
and possibly the worst time in
Trailblazer history okay so what which
when was this oh three oh four uh mo
cheeks was the coach
they were the gel Blazers in in one
season so I returned in the PR
department which this is like a crash
course and like the PR and spin and
press releases and constantly
apologizing for what other people had
done this was like this is what I was
running to the so in one season
stottlemeyers house got broken into and
someone left a half a pound of weed at
his front doorstep while the team was
out of town and the cops showed up
bonzi Wells proclaimed himself the COBE
stopper to which Kobe didn't drop like
40 points on him every single
gain shoutout to Kobe for that and then
Rasheed Wallace bonzi wails Ruben
Patterson and one other player got
arrested driving from Seattle after a
game when the Sonics were still up there
they drove home and got arrested for
smoking of course I can all I can
imagine is like the doors opening like
smoke just billowing like Cheech and
Chong or something I'm sure Gus it was a
pretty finale of season so you're
working as an intern in the public
relations department a day what what job
did you in fact have to help spend the
jail blazars so I did so like I actually
I mean I learned how to write a press
release which never even knew those were
things doctor have points but I also did
like on on court stuff I get in some of
the on court marketing's like when fans
come down and they can do all the like
contests and spin around the circle and
shoot the free throws but the PR stuff
was literally you know post game they
have the interview room yeah like my job
was literally to go get players and
bring them to the interview room
by the way like every single player
after the game was like in the locker
room trying to light a blunt and like
okay please do like I felt so bad for it
she's in such a zone that such an
amazing coach and these were great
players but like they were just out of
control
and like these dudes would literally be
in the locker room like strip down and
change and our ratings like hey so um we
just got to take you into the room for a
second just do this interview yeah I'll
be in there in a minute okay okay okay
mr. well sir let me what could you say
you know I mean to do with like six
eight will make 20 million dollars a
year how is she was he good to deal with
she was cool she was Rashid both teams
play hard both teams play hard I just
created we both I mean Russia was
receipt you know that wasn't that wasn't
that was who he was but you know he was
a good dude I mean I think you know it's
just it was there were a lot of eyes on
those guys at the time and they were
young and there was a lot of pressure
and you know they didn't want anyone
telling them how to do it it's funny I
just saw jealous of insecure on HBO
Sunday nights 10:30 p.m. Eastern here in
the Rich Eisen show I just saw bonds
Ewell's at the big three playing the big
three cubes big three league in Staples
yeah Brock when I had forgotten he
called himself
the Kobe story thought yeah so did Ruben
Patterson right also they are he was a
Kobe stop and Chloe showed them yeah I
mean I think he literally dropped 40 on
them like every single game like forget
Iran but he'd have like 40 that we have
really forever but he dropped like 40
something on them like every single game
that had to be a head slap moment in the
pr2 polygon it was also the year that kg
won MVP and had a triple-double I will
never forget this this dude had a
triple-double halfway through the second
quarter it was the most amazing thing to
watch it was it was it was insane kg kg
yeah now you know he's now he's on TNT
with his swear button and doing all this
and so you being your dad being from
Sacramento leading you to the 49ers how
come you're not at Kingston no we didn't
do the Kings you drew the line at there
we just so water so we are you clipper
or Laker what are you here in this town
man you're the one and you know what it
is are you you know we didn't see Ellis
fandom is up for grabs right it is
here's my thing I was a Kobe fan for so
and still AM and wish he would come back
if I would love to watch him play until
he literally couldn't do they were
willing them around he couldn't walk
anymore but I was a Kobe fan so that I
think that by-proxy made me a Laker fan
Blake Griffin as well is from Oklahoma
so yeah I've been a sure I've been a fan
of his ever since high school and
college right I guess I'm a clip of Fame
so how did you get in acting then how
did you get to this point where you are
in your career um I took a couple
classes when I was in college but I
wouldn't tell anybody because I couldn't
walk into the locker room after a game
and be like hey by the way guys I'm
doing Pippen tonight if you guys want to
come check me out and they play they
might start out that's got a big
probably that's the Pippen it is that's
the only Commission but that's all he
could but they knew for sure right um
like off the backboard no not that
Pippen not that Pippin um so I ended up
moving to New York for a little bit
modeled that was a horrible experience I
moved to LA and I got to LA and just
thought like Oh imma be The Fresh Prince
like somebody is like there's an agent
somewhere waiting for me to just even
know what agents were actually I just
thought some person was going to give me
a show to be the next wheels message
with ourselves no no to bel-air like I'm
a few blocks away why not so I got a job
working at Sports Club la which is now
Equinox Turlough the William endeavor
Roy Morris Endeavor boon I know that the
big agencies right on Canada Boulevard
yes I used to think that like Oh some
agent is going to come in and see me and
think you know where you been man we got
like three studio movies for you we're
doing it Independence Day reboot a men
in black reboot like this you're the guy
we've been waiting up for you
Will Smith is looking for like a younger
version of him to play in the next bad
boys I'm about to do bad boys 3 here we
go Chris so I got this job working at
Sports Club early I was handing out
towels and locker room keys at 5 o'clock
in the morning to - mm-hmm most agents
would walk in and they'd be in their
BlackBerry's like this BlackBerry's
click click clack click clack clack
clack like a towel key okay yep uh-huh
Thanks click click clack clack lock and
they never made eye contact never would
even look up and so I did that for a few
years and then I got like this part-time
job I was the Al Bundy of the Beverly
Center like I sold women's shoes in the
Beverly Center for 50 years
I was just as grumpy about Bundy - Oh a
lot okay and then a few years later I
had this job and realized that it wasn't
for me and got an acting class and I was
you know felt like if I was going to be
in LA this is what I moved here for and
so I took acting class for a couple
years and started auditioning and
nothing and now here you are and on a
show on HBO um you know part of the game
of Thrones dollars is cured and last
week tonight that's it this is really
great how you enjoying it looks like
you're having fun on the set of this
show and insecure yeah it's a lot of fun
we're a big family we we really get we
really get to enjoy like just being
around each other and I think that's
that's really really cool HBO's been so
great
just supporting us in supporting the
show and and just you know when we're
out doing promo and press and all that
stuff they've just been really really
supportive and even given us that time
slot you know to come on after Game of
Thrones and after ball was which were
two of their biggest shows it's just
like you know such a such a great thing
for them well congrats on that come back
anytime you want
certainly during the the hoop season
we'll see if you're a clipper
your lungs of all John at that point in
time we'll see that and let's stay in
touch come back anytime tritiated you
got at j.r Ellis yeah on Twitter don't
don't forget that our four room oh we
think my grandmother was cheating with a
Puerto Rican guy
it's Sara no mom we don't know J Ramone
Ellis JR Alice on Twitter here on their
judgment the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you like
that please download our app there's
lots of fun things there other than just
more of the videos you just saw you can
call us from the app you can email us
from the app just download it trust me
you'll enjoy